[Music]
the kangaroo one of australia's most
recognizable marsupials
there are a handful of species found all
over the country from the antillipine
kangaroo in the far northern reaches to
the aptly named eastern gray
the only large animal to hop as a
primary means of travel many can cover
25 feet almost 8 meters in a single
bound while reaching sprinting speeds as
high as 35 miles or 56 kilometers per
hour
their genus name of macropus literally
means bigfoot with some standing over
six feet or two meters tall they have
the height to match
kangaroos are social animals that forage
together in a group called a troop herd
or mob
as herbivores they eat a variety of
plants and grasses
kangaroos graze similar to cows and
goats with the same cud chewing
abilities
recently swallowed food can be
regurgitated and chewed again before
final digestion
as they forage along their tail acts as
a kind of fifth leg helping to push off
from the ground
one of their most apparent features
however is the female pouch
here the offspring called joey's spend
their time until mature enough to emerge
anywhere from four to thirteen months
depending on the species
before hitting the pouch the tiny barely
inch long newborn needs to find its way
there
blind and with the use of its forelimbs
only it instinctively crawls through its
mother's thick fur
once inside the pouch the newborn begins
to nurse
when it eventually leaves the pouch it
can continue to suckle from its mother
for up to a year or more
amazingly female kangaroos can be
perpetually pregnant
a joey can be developing inside the
pouch while an embryo is held in a sort
of suspended animation known as a diapas
waiting for its sibling to leave
to accommodate females produce two
distinct types of milk one higher in fat
for newborns and another for more mature
joeys
in poor environmental conditions such as
dry spells or limited food kangaroos
will often stop breeding altogether
they'll resume having offspring once
resources become stable
kangaroo mothers tend to give birth to
females first relegating males to later
in life
no one knows exactly how or why they do
this though the core bond of a mob
revolves around clusters of females
males usually wander off around
adolescence so the sisterhood looks
after itself
whether jacks or jills these mascots of
australia are both abundant and
impressive
[Music]
you